Vsauce!
5 Classic Monster Makeups, 4 TV & Movie Costumes,
3 Video game Costumes, 2 Creepy Costumes and
1 Amazing Costume.
It's five, four, three, two...
One Amazing Costume.
This cemetery angel costume was submitted
by Tiffany from Virginia to Coolest Homemade
Costumes dot com.
She cut the wings by hand out of foam board,
used an old sheet and fabric paint for the
dress, and yarn for the hair.
Two Creepy Costumes.
Youtuber Dannylynnforever made this gruesome
makeup tutorial of a girl with her eye ripped
out.... and sewn shut with safety pins.
She shows you how to make the prosthetic used
in this video on her blog as well as all the
materials you need to recreate this gory makeup.
And her channel has other gnarly makeup including
this slashed mouth makeup and this zombie.
On her blog "Love thing" Sara creates this
creepy rendition of a nutcracker doll.
Proving that for Halloween you don't have
to be gruesome to be frightening.
She did it all with makeup and didn't use
any special face paints.
Three Video Game Costumes.
These great Halo costumes of Master Chief
and Warrior were handmade by Charles from
New Jersey.
He used paper craft and foam and the weapons
of PVC pipe and EVA foam.
Youtuber ohaple made a Bioshock splicer rabbit
mask and a Borderlands Psycho mask.
He has tutorials on how to make these including
how to make the different types of LED lights
used in the mask and the blood splatter.
Emma Pickles has a great channel where she
creates makeup costumes like this Black Ops
2 Zombie.
She used this as her reference photo that
you can check out if you'd like to try it
yourself and the description of the video
lists all the materials she used and where
to get them including the bald cap and even
the different types of brushes.
Four TC and Movie Halloween Costumes.
Lex from MadeYewLook made this great Jack
Nicholson version of the Joker with makeup
and body paint.
Her channel is filled with fun movie character
halloween costumes like the Pumpkin King Jack
Skellington, Jessica Rabbit and Jason Voorhees.
Another amazing costume by Emma Pickles is
this Edward Scissorhands.
She goes into step by step detail on recreating
the Scissorhands look and she has a bunch
of other geeky makeups like Stahma Tarr from
Defiance, Mystique from X-Men, and Daenerys
Targaryen from Game of Thrones.
SmashinBeauty becomes Heisenberg when she
transforms herself into Walter White's alter
ego from Breaking Bad.
She also adds little skits in the beginning
of her tutorials for fun, like this one where
she creates her own version of the "blue meth"
from Breaking Bad on a kiddie stove.
Pete Mander at kre8fx production made this
incredible Broly costume from Dragon Ball
Z. Mander builds costumes for private collectors
and his website has a ton of beautiful creations
including many from the Alien movies and Predator.
Five Classic Monster Makeups.
Youtube Channel Extremesfx has a great tutorial
on becoming a Vampire.
If you follow all the steps you should be
able to make yourself look something like
this!
They give you tips on applying the prosthetic,
blending it in and what type of contact lenses
to use.
A lot of people are scared of clowns because
of images like this one, created by Youtuber
eRaness.
In 11 minutes he shows you how to go from
normal to terrifying and his channel features
other classic characters like this skull and
this alien.
ReeRee creates this classic mummy look using
just face paint.
The right amount of shading adds realism and
depth.
Try it yourself with her help and check out
her other great tutorials like Mortica Addams
from the Addams family.
LetzMakeup is a great channel that has makeup
intricate and elaborate makeup tutorials like
this skull.
She also shows you two ways to become the
wicked witch!
This way or this way.
A few weeks ago Stan Winston Studios turned
me into a zombie.
The entire process was documented from start
to finish and being made into a zombie is
what inspired this video in the first place!
Okay I hope that inspired you to make an awesome
costume for this Halloween.
If you need your brain stimulated right now
I made a brand new riddle challenge over on
WEsauce.
While you're there Jake has a new JAM or Just
Awesome Music playlist for you to listen to
and if that's not enough music - the first
ever YouTube Music Awards are going on right
after Halloween on November 3rd.
So have a safe and fun Halloween.
And as always - thanks for watching!